yes i know this is the episode that
actually gives us the proper
introduction of the sonic specs and
actually name drops them in they
use for the first time but i don't know
i'm not sure i was feeling the
sunglasses for the whole review
[Music]
suppose it could just be ego and i may
just want you to bask in the glory of my
eyes
now whatever the witch is familiar part
two of the opening
two-part story for series nine
and um a bit like the magician's
apprentice
some really good moments like
some excellent moments
but a lot of little bits here and there
things that i either
had forgotten about or had
chosen to ignore that i'm like
[Music]
and now looking at again with
more life experience i can't help but
notice these things so
it opens with oh there's clara and missy
so obviously
they weren't dead which again
just emphasizes how pointless
having oh they're dead as one of the
cliff hangers to the previous episode
because
and again it's not a surprise we knew
they weren't dead but it's kind of
insulting that you even
tried to play it off like maybe they
were
and especially if you're just going to
immediately go no look they're still
live
like yeah we know that said
i do still really like the interactions
between clara
and missy missy especially oh
god she's got so much good stuff in this
i really love
the pointy stick i think i even said it
at the time
that i wanted the pointy stick to become
a staple
of missy i wanted the pointy stick to
come back
and like that's a weird desire for me to
have but like i
i did want that owl but the two of them
going back and forth especially when you
get little moments where clara
i don't think clara is ever stupid
enough to consciously trust
missy but she does have moments where
she lets her guard down
just enough for missy to mess with her
in some way whether it be
handcuffing her to this thing or um
my favorite moment it's too dark um
we could chuck a stone down or something
oh yeah good idea
[Music]
20 feet like i love that like that's the
kind of stuff i'm
so here for i love missy for that kind
of stuff
and she's really well utilized we've got
another instance
where it feels like they're really going
out of their way to big up
how smart clara is it's not as egregious
as
last episode where they did it by
dumbing another character down here it's
through the scene
of missy telling clara this story of
some time the doctor was captured before
and got away
and she quizzes clara you know how does
he always get out
how did he get out of this one and while
you know in and of itself in a vacuum
it's
fine because you know clara knows this
doctor well enough that she understands
the way he thinks and she can come up
with these things and like
that's fine but the problem is
between that and the previous episode
and where i know things are ultimately
going
it's creating a pattern of things really
going out of their way to big up
her brains as opposed to letting these
moments happen more organically
because both this and the scene that i
mentioned between her
and kate stewart in the previous episode
they feel like they're pausing the story
to have these scenes
or at least to extend them for as long
as they do
and so this desire is kind of
intruding in on the flow of the story a
little bit again not massively
egregiously and this is certainly better
than what happened last episode
but i i'm noticing him i've been i'm
watching for it now
i've become attuned to it so i'm
catching it much more than i did
previously there is um there's actually
a
surprising number of things
set up that will pay off later in the
season
some of which are very clearly setups
and some of which are a bit more subtle
and which i rather like like i like
during the scene that i just criticized
i'm about to say something i like about
it yes
i can have these contradictory things
going on
i'm complicated or maybe i'm just
confused and mad i don't know
but in any case she points out that the
reason the doctor survives is because
he always assumes he's going to win and
that basically works backwards from that
assumption
and we see that very deliberately in
action later on in heaven sent
where i think it's while he's falling
whereas you know
assume you're going to survive then
figure out how you do it and it's
it's nice that that gets called back and
that is a more organic instance of
something being planted that's going to
pay off later
far less organic is the name drop
and the concept of the hybrid
everyone's a better both everyone's a
hybrid
i'm gonna really be keeping an eye on
that because i haven't done a ranking
of the series arcs for doctor who yet
it's on my eventual to-do list i'll do
it at some point
but i feel like the hybrid
is one of the weakest ones
largely because it's so weird and
nebulous
and it's initially planted here in a
very weak and nebulous way that
highlights the word
you know with this big pause and this
dramatic saying of it which first of all
god i hate that i i just i hate that big
let's go out of our way let's let's
let's kneecap the way this dialogue is
delivered to to highlight a word
come on you're going to be repeating it
across the series we're going to catch
that it keeps coming up
you didn't have to alert us right here
hybrid oh well i guess we keep an eye
out for
hybrid later on instead of you know us
learning that it's something that's
going to keep coming back because you
know
as much as i don't love bad wolf
at least that was something that they
just kept running into
and it didn't get highlighted until
almost halfway through the season
actually more than halfway i think it
was boom town so like
just a couple episodes from the finale
they finally draw attention to the fact
that they keep running into that
prior to that they expected you just to
notice
which shows more respect for the
audience than this
does so
davos and the doctor and their whole
scene
together it's really good
it's really well acted i mentioned
julian beach's
performance as davros doing a really
good job of selling
this person being at the end of their
life and the thing is
for the conversation that they have even
for someone
like davros
i buy it because i don't care who you
are
if you are dying and you know you're
dying and you're dying in a way that is
not
instantaneous that isn't over quick that
doesn't give you a chance to go out in a
blaze of glory but it's something that's
going to
linger and give you time
to second guess everything you've ever
done
you're going to have a little bit of a
personal crisis in your last moments
i think most people would especially
people who have done as
big sweeping and you know people saying
you shouldn't be doing this sort of
things as someone like davros did
so to me that conversation
tracks it makes sense that even someone
as vile as davros
if he's at the end of his life
he would still ask was i right i need
to know before the end was i right
was i a good man to which the answer is
obviously
no no
but it's still valid for him to ask that
that makes sense to me
all of this gets undermined immediately
because it's revealed to be a trap which
has two big problems with it the first
is i buy davoros as a lot of things
i buy him as a technical genius i buy
him as a scientific genius as a
as a maniac as a genocidal lunatic
i don't buy him as a world-class actor
which is what he now needs to add to his
resume
if he didn't break character for this
whole thing and the doctor didn't pick
up on it
so that's problem number one with the
scene but even if i
bought it even if i didn't question that
it completely undercuts the scene that
came before
and it wouldn't bother me if that scene
hadn't been so
good and gone on for as long as it did
if this if it had been
quicker if it had been the instant the
doctor
starts to think maybe this is real that
you know they
lash him to the cables or whatever and
siphon
the the regeneration energy out of him
fine but the fact that the scene goes on
for as long as it does
and it is playing on the doctor's
compassion
and it means that davoros is right
his compassion was a weakness now i know
from davos's perspective it is and he's
trying to exploit that
but now the narrative is also saying
that the doctor would have been better
off if he'd never come and let a dying
man just die
if he had not been a doctor
and come to somebody's bedside things
would have been better
off i don't like that that's what the
narrative
is saying because structurally it is
structurally it's saying the doctor made
a mistake and he should not have had
compassion for this person
the other thing i don't like about this
is that you
you can now never pull that trigger
again
now let's be honest the idea of a
repentant davoros
is a tricky one to even try and think
about doing because
you don't want to lose him as a villain
he
cannot be redeemed fully
as a cat he can't you just
can't but you can still have him be
repentant
but you can only ever do that once and
if you're gonna have him repent
but not retire the character in the
process of doing so
and then do this well now we can never
have that scene we can never have that
seen genuinely
and if you never intend
for something this prolonged
this emotional this well executed to
have meaning over time if you're
planning to undermine it and
initially my honest answer is don't do
it
you are burning off great material
for the sake of a fake out and i've
really especially in
as i've aged i've really come to resent
that
i i'm not saying you can't do fake outs
but it really ticks me off when the fake
premise
is deeper and more interesting and more
theoretically impactful
than the oop no we're not doing that
like oh for god's sake
it's it's like um it's like when tom
king
said he was going to actually have
catwoman batman get married he's like oh
no we're definitely doing it because you
know
everyone says you can't and i think
there's new stories to explore i'm like
yes that's right and then guess what
they don't do it
if you were never going to do it then
don't burn off
the idea for a fake out
just ticks me off so since i'm on an
annoyed rant at this point with this
episode i've got a lot more bad things
to say than i thought i did um let's get
to clara in the tank
so first off it is a callback to
oswin and the first appearance of jenna
coleman in the show back in asylum of
daleks
cool it is one more way that missy
tricks and manipulates and messes with
clara cool
it's the voice alterations
that i have problems with moffitt
decided to do something
and didn't think through the
implications of what he was doing
say you are different from me
you are different from me
here's the problem with that i mean it
like for the purposes of this story
alone
it works because it puts clara in a
situation where
the doctor has to deduce or she has to
somehow convince with the incredibly
limited vocabulary she now has
the doctor that she's in there and for
the purposes
only of this story that's fine here's
the problem
the minute you expand that out into the
rest of the show
this means that it is feasible
that there have been daleks
who begged to not get killed
who wanted to surrender who wanted to do
something other than
kill everything but the tank makes them
say exterminate
if they get emotional the thing starts
firing
and they could be pleading
with the doctor please don't kill me
and it will come out as exterminate the
doctor
and the doctor will have no com
compulsions
against doing just that wiping them out
the thing about the daleks is
they they are like if you didn't know
this you should
they are intended to be
nazis they are based very deliberately
especially if you've seen genesis of the
daleks
it is very clear what the
allegory is and tara nation was not
subtle about that the original creator
of the daleks
having it be this race that is
this single mind this universally
single-minded simplifies things
injecting this real world
admittedly element of maybe
they repent
but nobody hears and they're going to
get killed anyway
it muddies the waters not just for this
doctor but every doctor because
every doctor has faced the daleks every
doctor has
brought doom to daleks
and now we're looking at the possibility
that maybe some of those daleks
didn't even want to attack the doctor
and wanted to
run away and beg to be spared
but the tank didn't let them
it's a way of being able to argue
maybe there are some good dialects
and i don't think that's an argument
that should be made by doctor who
especially not for the allegorical
influence of the daleks
it muddies the water for who the doctor
is it muddies the water for what the
daleks represent i just do not think
stephen moffat thought through the
implications of this idea
at all he just did it oh trying to think
if there's anything else positive for me
to say
um you know the whole sewers thing that
was set up pretty well
that was a decent payoff made sense
tracked um and
for what was happening it doesn't feel
like as much of a technobab that will
pull it out of your rear end kind of
resolution
so good work there uh we had as i said
the introduction of the sonic specs
which
i know some people hate those i like
them
for the for the phase of his life that
this doctor is going through i think
they make sense and i like them
so uh in this story actually last
episode i forgot to mention we also get
the
introduction of the confession dial and
that's unlike the hybrid thing that's a
decent placement because
it has utility within this story so you
don't necessarily think oh that's
something that'll pay off
later there's maybe some implications
like what's he confessed to but
like it has usefulness and utility here
already
so it's not as much of a blatant drop
for stuff that will happen later as some
of the other stuff going on so
that works pretty well again this is
mostly the performances
my issue largely is the writing and with
some things undercutting other scenes i
i love clara and missy's interactions
great stuff i love the scene with
davorus and the doctor but then it gets
undercut
the so much of the stuff going on with
the daleks gets
made very weird by what happens with
clara
and it's just a bit of a mix
as an episode i'm not sure i'm prepared
to call it bad
but the things that bother me about it
on a re-watch really bother me
so that's the which is familiar have you
re-watched it lately what'd you think
about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it
you know what the stuff there is to do
like and subscribe share this around hit
the bell
i've got merch i've got a patreon it is
keeping these lights
on right now and all that sort of stuff
links in the description but um you also
don't have to
end of the day you're the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]